hi everyone in this video we'll talk
about rheumatoid arthritis
so rheumatoid arthritis is an autoimmune
disorder
and the key cause of rheumatoid
arthritis
is an auto antibodies and these auto
antibodies
can harm our joints and they can be
getting deposited
into these joints of our limbs
especially our hands
but rheumatoid arthritis is not limited
to these joints it can also affect other
organs such as lungs and the heart
so according to who report
this is the statistics of death
occurring from rheumatoid arthritis
in 2000
now the cases of rheumatoid arthritis
is increasing day by day and this is the
data for
last three decades so what is rheumatoid
arthritis
so if you look at the person which is
having a rheumatoid arthritis look at
his finger it is kind of swallowing
distorted
and the joints are kind of swollen
so if we look at the cellular details
we would see why these joints are
inflamed
so imagine that we are doing an x-ray
and we are able to see it
so what would happen is these joints
are getting inflamed in rheumatoid
arthritis
and what is the cause of this
inflammation in order to understand that
we have to understand the basic
immunology behind it right what is the
actual cause the actual cause
is an auto antibody but before
understanding about auto antibody
let me tell you that we have circulatory
igg antibodies
which are against many pathogens for
example there is a virus invasion these
igg antibodies would try to
oxidize the virus and neutralize the
virus so these are good for our body
the circulatory antibodies but in rare
occasions there could be
antibodies against these antibodies
so antibody against this antibody could
be harm
so you can see this igm antibody is
determining or
detecting the fc region of these igg
as a result it is forming a immune
complex
and it can lead to immune complex
mediated type 3 hypersensitivity
response
if you don't know what is type 3
hypersensitivity response
you can click on the link in the i
button this would lead you to a detailed
video on that
but coming back to this picture let's
see what are the immune responses
happening
so these complexes these antibody
complexes would be now getting deposited
into these
joints so let's look at look at a joint
in bit more details
so if you see the joint of your fingers
you would see there is fibrous capsule
inside that there would be synovial
membrane
and there is a synovial cavity which is
filled up with synovial fluid
and this ensures that there is a smooth
frictionless movement of our joints
so in case of rheumatoid arthritis these
antigen
and these antibody complexes or these
immune complexes are deposited
near the synovial membrane and these
immune complexes are able to
fix complement so the ah synoviocytes
which are lining this synovial membrane
gets heavily affected by these
immune complexes and that leads to
complement fixation
and thereby lysis of the cell by a
complement fixation
response now other than that
these cells can attract other cell types
such as macrophages dendritic cells
because these cells
are phagocytic right they would try to
engulf and clear up these things but
they are now attractive
once they engulf these things these
dendritic cell and macrophages are
activated and they secretes several
cytokines
and most of these cytokines are
inflammatory ones such as il1
il-6 or tnf alpha along with these
there are other cell types which join
them
such as t helper one type cells and it
increase the inflammation and makes the
situation even worse
so this is a normal situation in the
left hand side where you can see the
rheumatoid arthritis situation on the
right hand side
you can see many things are totally
wrong in case of rheumatoid arthritis
the synovial membrane is damaged and
there is a thickening of these membrane
and there is quite a lot of overall
inflammation that has been there
now let's talk about
what else happen so
these macrophages which were activated
can now secrete inflammatory cytokines
many of these inflammatory cytokines
turns out to activate
osteoclast activity and thereby
it triggers bone erosion and it's making
the joints more rigid
hard and less flexible
so this is detrimental for a person
right
so mobility of the joint is gone due to
this kind of inflammatory response and
enhanced osteoblast
osteoclast activity and overall there is
an inflammation sensation that is
persisting
rheumatoid arthritis increases
like your risk of developing several
other associated symptoms such as
many medications which are used to treat
rheumatoid arthritis
or the way rheumatoid arthritis occurs
the immune response
that leads to triggering of the
osteoporosis
so it makes the bone more perforated
more sponge like
and weaker then there is a symptom which
is known as
rheumatoid nodules these are
kind of like bumps especially in the
pressure points such as elbows
or let's say in the ankles so these
are due to these these are actually
rheumatoid nodules
which are painful actually then there is
increased chance of developing carpal
tunnel symptom
which is numbness of specific area in
the
hand in the pump now there could be
increased risk of lung disease and heart
disease
which are harmful manifestations of
rheumatoid arthritis now there are
several factors which
increase the risk of rheumatoid
arthritis
such as the gender related issues it has
been seen
females are more susceptible to develop
rheumatoid arthritis
compared to male family history is
another issue
rheumatoid arthritis is not totally
sporadic there could be genetic reasons
to it smoking
environmental issues and obesity are
also considered to be the important
risk factors so treatment options are
there but there is no
absolute treatment there is no complete
cure
so medications like nsaid and
corticosteroids could be helpful to
reduce the inflammation
but they don't help in the long run so
they just improve the situation minutely
there is no
long term cure available till now but
people are trying to develop
immunotherapies
which would be more efficient than these
ones so in summary we have looked at
what is rheumatoid arthritis
what is the immunological responses
happening in rheumatoid arthritis
risk factor associated with rheumatoid
arthritis and the treatment option
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
do let me know in the comment how you
like my videos
and please support me in patreon and if
you like my videos
and if you like my courses you can
access my full-fledged courses on
immunology and many other topics in an
academy which is india's biggest
learning platform
using my code ap 10 you can get a 10
discount so hurry up thank you guys
thanks for listening